Opinions determine our experience of life.
More than anything else, our opinions provide
us with who we think we are and how we see
the world.
As a result, we hold our opinions very tightly,
for we fear that if we lose them, we will
become void of our identity.
We hate few things more in life than having
someone oppose and strip us of an opinion.
When our opinions are challenged and proven
wrong, it often feels as though our identity
has been weakened and diminished.
But why must this be the case?
It is not our identity that is being challenged,
but merely an extension of it.
Our opinions are like glasses.
Through which, we view and discern the world
around us.
But just like how overtime the prescription
of one’s glasses may change, so must our
opinions.
As our understanding of life changes, the
prescription of our opinions must change with
it.
For another opinion to disprove our own only
serves to benefit us because it gives us the
opportunity to replace our old lenses for
potentially new and improved ones.
All the while, our identity as the individual
who is wearing the glasses can remain integral
and constant.
And so, we must learn how to accept and embrace
this process as a positive thing.
More important than having opinions in life,
is having good ones.
Progressive ones.
Sharp ones.
The only way to possess opinions with such
sharpness is through the willingness to listen
to and consider other opinions with rationality
and objectivity, and see if compared to ours,
they provide a clearer and improved image
of the world.
We should embrace our own opinions and fight
to defend them, but only once we have removed
our ego from the equation and considered the
opposing opinions with legitimate open-mindedness.
There is very little that any person can be
certain about in this life, and we must self-admit
that we are all merely humans with a constantly
changing and loose grip of reality.
We have opinions to help us navigate and create
meaning in life, but we must not let them
in combination with our ego, sweep us away
into believing that we are able to construe
an ultimate reality.
Just as others have the potential to have
misled opinions, so don’t you.
As we are introduced to new experiences, ideas,
and understandings in life, our opinions must
change accordingly.
And if we are willing to adapt, our identity
can move fluidly with them.
Our life will then improve because we will
become able to rationalize and exchange opinions
with others in a cohesive and beneficially
effective way.
By slightly detaching your ego and identity
from your opinions, you can embrace the fact
that you are not always right, and as a result,
you will not always
be wrong.